do you ever just sit down and do nothing  and just watch TV you know I watch a lot  of movies you do yeah I watch about a  movie a day I tried to a movie a day  yeah is that right yeah I love movies I  grew up loving movies and had jobs and  went to movies and well absolutely but  that's I mean what movies do you watch  when I grew up I got to make movies and  do you watch you don't watch your own  movies do you those are the only films  that I watch over  I just watch nothing but your own  no I watch I watch all the films that  come out my first apartment I had in New  York I just I didn't buy drapes or  anything like that I just I had the  biggest television that I could get yeah  with all of the systems LaserDisc and  VHS laserdist was my I was one of the  investors of laser desk is that right  we both lost in that game